let's lighten the mood we got some good
news we got some good news we're gonna
we're gonna give everybody good news
because we get all heated and stuff we
got this story right here check this out
lieutenant colonel stewart sheller is
released from the brig today
marine who was jailed for criticizing
afghanistan withdrawal goes free after
landslide of public support the military
said his lawyers reached an agreement
with the marines he was put in
confinement last month monday after
posting a video criticizing the
withdrawal from afghanistan shelter
condemned the catec effort that killed
13 service members so he kept speaking
they told him if you don't shut up we're
gonna lock you in the brig and he said
i'm not gonna shut up so they'll lock
him in the break good for him yeah bravo
this is a guy who stood up who risked
everything and said lock me up i'm not
backing down
so what does this show us
it's not about just stuart sheller
it's about massive public support there
was a wave of support saying don't do
this you can't do this he raised
millions of dollars from from fans who
are supporting him whatever is politics
apparently he doesn't like trump
supporters or whatever i'm i'm not
concerned with that
he stood up he challenged the
unaccountable these military leaders
people like millie who are crackpots and
he got punished for he got attacked for
it well now he's being released i hope i
hope he he comes out you know squeaky
clean i hope he makes a good living up
to write writes a book i hope he finds a
career in standing up and speaking out
against the the the corruption and
unaccountability that we have in in our
government and our military and all that
stuff but anyway the the good news here
is aside from his release
you can do it right it's possible to win
well we're going to see what's going to
happen with that particular case but
it's it's it's daunting that he was the
only one punished over the whole
afghanistan debacle over everything that
happened the one person held responsible
the one person that the rules actually
applied to was a guy sitting back and
making a youtube video no no facebook
video excuse me you said held
responsible and rules applied to i i i
disagree i think he didn't i mean okay
maybe the rules are arguably being
broken but he's not being held
responsible was he responsible for
saying that we should as a country live
up to our ideals and our standards and
hold our leaders accountable for their
uh horrible actions that's the
foundation of this country not something
responsible for us to be something to be
cherished for yeah well i misspoke there
and i agree with you on that sentiment
but when we look at afghanistan my
goodness the utter mess the utter
distraction i mean this couldn't get any
worse than you could even imagine it to
be especially with the drone bombing of
an innocent aid worker and seven
children i mean when you have actions
committed like this and then the guy
criticizing it goes to jail and then you
get propped up you get to lie on
national media say that you went after
isis k whatever that propaganda the term
means whatever made up invention the
pentagon just came out of thin air just
to justify this bull crap i mean you got
to be kidding me this is the gut
this is they bombed a car with seven
children inside of it and an aid worker
that was working for a u.s organization
that was delivering water and aid to
local communities he was a person that
was well respected in afghanistan for
helping people who needed help and the
us bombed him and then lied about him
and said he was trying to kill people
because he was filling up waters in his
back they knowingly lied to everyone
with this larger propaganda story and
then this is the same president that
that did this that is calling people
like putin killers you know the problem
is if we're if we're going to consider
this like a really inept malicious
military ex experience like the whole us
government is just it's just
fallaciously dangerous let's just see
yeah they armed the taliban with
billions of dollars of machine guns and
weaponry things that i wish i could own
and have that i will never be able to
have because of government regulations
the taliban now has with my tax dollars
i think my problem is that we're using
state-funded propaganda media right now
google i'm talking to you alphabet to
talk about it and that's a big problem
because if you're going to use the nazis
propaganda to bash the nazis it's not
going to go very far and i know i can't
i can't say what i want to say on this
tv show because of censorship
this is like the worst military debacle
in the last
100 years
i don't know
the last 20 years of war afghanistan
america the united states the greatest
country ever
yeah it was all ruse it was all based on
lies and the military industrial complex
milked it to the last drop until even to
the point where where the afghanistan
papers came out when the washington post
even released documentation showing that
it's all a scam nothing's happening here
no one's being trained no one's being
helped there's no mission here no one
knows what's going on here years ago
um still it still continued and when it
was ended it was ended i think
deliberately bad uh for a very specific
reason and it could have been ended
totally differently there could have
been different approaches and it's just
it's just mind-boggling but we we
we've had the afghanistan conversation
50 times yeah the issue here was the
optimism
that this guy who spoke up has been
released
yeah but it's like a story that's like
the headline might as well be man stops
beating his wife
that's a good point you got a point you
got a good point there yeah yeah i mean
i i don't see the optimism in that well
at least he stopped
exactly
after a large public campaign he agreed
to stop beating his wife for now
but it shows you again the
politicization of the security state uh
the politicization of of anyone who
speaks out against the agenda against
the narrative uh they want people
fearful they want people afraid to speak
out they want people afraid to stand up
they want people to to buckle down and
be afraid of them we need google and
alphabet on our side and i know there
are people i know you're listening and
you believe us and you believe me
and we need you
think that was actually a really
profound point that you made about yeah
because i think it in some ways it
attests to how hungry we are for some
like a scruple of good news just like
one good like silver lining to you know
focus on for a minute and it's actually
like
watching someone dig a hole
and then when you hear that they filled
the hole we're like yay the whole was
filled but it's like the person caused
the problem in the first place you know
so yeah thanks ian yeah excited
i'm out
actually i think i have to go to the
bathroom which is also
right now
i was like this is some good news this
guy's getting released i mean look it is
still good news because
we expect people who challenge the
machine in the establishment to speak
out against unaccountable leaders to get
punished permanently and there was a big
you know a cry of support for this guy
he did get out and there are a lot of
people who aren't
you know facing that same you know level
of um relief i guess there are a lot of
people who have challenged the machine
and get locked up for it for a long time
and i don't mean you know violent
individuals i mean like people who speak
out speak up and get punished we don't
hear about in the news
so this just shows that if people do
come together victory is achievable
as much as you made a good point i look
at what happens in new york at the
vaccine mandates and they say only 10
violations so far okay 21 000
inspections they didn't find anything
they got 5 000 800 warnings 10
violations
that says to me
because i've you know we had ariel on
the show the other day saying that she
doesn't get carded by anybody she goes
wherever she wants yeah that says to me
that if people just said no it would be
done with and you would win
but people aren't
some people are but more people need to
well it's all about the illusion of
power and if you could convince enough
people that you do have authority over
them you will and i think this is the
kind of silver lining this is the kind
of balance that a lot of these
politicians are playing they're like we
need to scare the crap out of these
people uh we need to make examples out
of people we need to punish people for
going against us and i think this is the
stage we're at now because people are
seeing how delicate and how vulnerable
this entire state is and how easily
everyone who
could just say hey i'm not going to
comply here that they can't really do
anything because there's more of us than
they are of them and even if you add up
the police even if you add up the
military there's a lot more citizenry
there's a lot more people who are
willing to do the right thing stand up i
i'm still optimistic in some ways i i i
think we still need optimism uh
just even if we're still in a very bad
position i think being optimistic is
still important
because you know the way that you see
things are the way that things kind of
usually kind of play out especially in
your mind your mind is extremely
powerful if you think resistance is
futile it is and i think that's what
they're trying to convince you of right
now uh it's futile you're gonna lose
don't you know look what we're you know
they're like stomping on people's
personal freedoms and liberties look
what we could get away with uh and in
reality it's it's kind of a
desperate insecure dance that they're
doing right now i don't think that
there's a bad outcome in whatever's
happening
i don't see a bad outcome i mean maybe
maybe for a lot of people they don't
want to live a different way than they
live and they're comfortable ordering
their pizza and wings and watching
football but life's going to change for
me i'm like all right let's let's just
imagine some scenarios joe biden is the
most divisive president ever or you
could say trump and biden were very
divisive for whatever reason i don't
think of trump's fault i think the media
did it but i think trump certainly was
divisive
then you get 2024 trump runs again the
left loses it john podesta gets his wish
the west coast secedes from the union
the country falls apart what happens i
don't know if you live in texas you
don't gotta worry about the atf anymore
you can have all these guns if you live
in new hampshire you got freedom if you
live in new york congratulations your
mandates are law everybody's taxes go
down substantially the federal
government is too powerful and needs to
be at least have its power kind of taken
back to the states and i think if
anything great i thought well as i was
relieving myself in the bathroom that
yeah it is good not only are you funny
but also that uh
public outcry man the power of public
outcry if that can overcome the military
then that's a good sign
i think it's happening
you know like we said with california
sanctuary state shows the emperor has no
clothes texas says atf no business here
ohio says it too i'm just like the
federal government yeah they're
panicking because they know their power
is just it's an illusion what are you
gonna say lydia so i just wanted to push
back a little bit because i feel like
what the states are doing like what
california is doing with the border i
think it's terrible but they're doing it
and what texas is doing what ohio is
doing with the atf i'm not convinced
it's like a form of divorce i think it's
states just disturbing their rights as
states i view this as being a very good
thing i'm a huge fan of the 10th
amendment and i think that if we were to
strip it all back to the states simply
upholding the duties that they're
supposed to we would be in a much better
place without needing any kind of
national divorce i think that states
just need to take that responsibility
and get back to it one of the things
that concerns me is not the federal
government really is that it's the deep
state the administrative state like the
cia where are they based they say it's
the pentagon right langley they say it's
probably underground somewhere and it's
all decentralized and like they have
satellites and control of weapons and
crazy lasers and like
how do you work against that or do you
work with it
is that the point hmm
no idea
reminds me of that uh star trek into
darkness the secret military base where
they were building the gigantic war
machine you see the movie
oh come on nope pop culture
reference that's it
i'm not pessimistic you know every day
when i'm recording my videos i look out
the window and there's deer and the
leaves are falling and i'm out here in
the middle of nowhere and i'm like dude
the federal government doesn't have the
ability to go state to state and enforce
90 of what they want to they can only go
after outliers
and so when joe biden goes nuts and and
basically violates the law and again i'm
i'm not saying
i oppose the federal government or
anything like that i actually think
america's fantastic i'm just saying
they've revealed they have no clothes
the more this stuff carries on the more
antifa is violent the more the states
reject federal law the federal
government is just freaking out it's
like
trying it's like you got a leak
if you're in a boat and a leak springs
and you can walk over and you can patch
that hole up as long as the only hole
but like in the cartoons more and more
holes are popping up and the feds have
no ability to actually go and deal with
all of them then eventually the boat
sinks
i don't think we're headed towards
anywhere dark though new hampshire wants
to be wants to be you know independent i
suppose texas probably does for the most
part people probably wouldn't even
notice or care other than
if you're in new hampshire your avocado
is probably going to get more expensive
unless you have a trade route going down
to florida or mexico and you're able
you're able to establish free trading
lines with good
communities yeah i mean it's all about
the the connections you have the
communities the neighborhoods the
friendships you have um that's one one
part why i try to travel as much as i
can to try to stay at as many homesteads
as i can as many farms as i can to try
to you know build and harbor good
relationships because i think that's
going to be something that's going to be
absolutely critically important and
that's why i see the federal government
trying to stop that at any way that they
can in the most dastardly way that they
can and there's an attack on cash
there's an attack on liberty there's an
attack on
personal responsibility and that's
because when you get rid of all those
things you'll need subjugated slaves
that will obey the government at all
costs thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to see the full show come back to
this channel youtube.com tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you